Speaker 1: Later in the show, we're going to talk
about the judge in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial.
And we're going to talk about the mom, Wendy
Rittenhouse in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial
later in the show. Now there is now a very wild
controversy involving the defense lawyer in the
case over the killing of Ahmaud Arbery, a trial
of multiple officers who killed Ahmaud Arbery.
And that case now is getting attention
because the defense attorney there
made a wild statement in court that he doesn't
want any more black pastors coming into the court
and sitting with the family of the victim,
Ahmaud Arbery. Now, when he said he doesn't
want more black pastors, any sensible person
who interprets language would say so. White
pastors would be OK because that sounds racial,
and that sounds crazy. Let's look at the clip.
This is attorney Kevin. I don't know. I don't
actually know whether it's pronounced Kevin Gow
or Kevin Guff. This case taking place in
Brunswick, Georgia. Here he is saying he's
been seeing black pastors coming in to sit with
the family of the victim. He doesn't want them
in there. Take a listen to this. This is crazy.
Speaker 2: And the idea that we're going to be
serially bringing these people in to sit with
the victim's family one after another now.
Speaker 1: These people, you
could say that's edgy enough,
but you don't have to wonder because he goes and
says, we can't have black pastors coming in here,
Speaker 2: obviously there's only so many
pastors they can have an effect on their pastors,
Al Sharpton, right now, that's fine. But
then that's it. We don't want any more black
pastors coming in here or otherwise.
Speaker 1: And if you're watching,
there's a woman you can actually see wearing
a red blazer who clearly is instinctive,
instinctively doing a double take, but then
resisting the double take and just playing it cool
because what this guy is saying is so bonkers.
Speaker 2: Jesse Jackson, whoever was in, was in
here earlier this week, sitting with the victim's
family, trying to influence the jury in this case.
And I'm not saying the state is even aware that
Mr. Sharpton was in the courtroom. I certainly
wasn't aware of it till last night. But I
think the court can understand my concern
about bringing people in who really don't have any
ties to this case other than political interests.
Speaker 1: Now he is not wrong about. Listen,
people are are not connected to the case, and
there is a degree to which this can be used to
influence the jury. You could make the argument,
by the way, there's a militia member who's been
sitting in the courtroom in the Kyle Rittenhouse
trial. We'll get to that later. But the idea
of people in the courtroom to influence juries
long standing topic the there's a legitimate point
to be made about tactics to influence juries. But
what is the relevance of black pastors? And
as soon as you open that door, you just sound
completely off the wall? And he then apologized,
but actually says, I've been asked to apologize.
Now what I love is that the judge actually
says, Listen. This court, meaning, you know,
in courts in the U.S., when they save the court,
they mean the judge, the judge is like, I didn't
ask you to apologize. So the fact that you've
been asked doesn't really mean anything to me,
which is great that the judge did this judge
making a lot more sense than the one in the
Rittenhouse trial. And then the apology also
includes this classic thing of if anyone was
inadvertently offended, then I apologize and
I've been asked to apologize. What it is? What
a sincere apology. I'm apologizing if anyone was
offended because I've been asked to by others.
Anyway, take a look at this. This is the apology
Unidentified: you are being asked to address and
comments. The other day in court has
Speaker 3: asked me to do that,
Unidentified: saying if I don't say
anything past whatever you've been
Speaker 3: asked to do is
not been asked by the court.
Very well. I will. It's already good. Here we go.
Now that get my statements yesterday were overly
broad, I will follow up with a more specific
Speaker 1: motion on Monday. What's funny is
the statements weren't overly broad. They were
too too narrow. That's actually the problem.
If he had said. More broadly, the revolving
door of pastors to sit with the family
may be a technique to influence the jury or if
he had even said the revolving door of public
figures coming in. It wasn't that he was too
broad, he wasn't broad enough. When you say the
problem is black pastors, it's not a problem of
breadth. It's a problem of specificity, putting
Speaker 3: many of those concerns in the
proper context. My apologies to anyone
who might have inadvertently given. All right.
Speaker 1: Kind of, Judge, I actually like this,
judge. It. I haven't watched as much of
the of this trial as the Rittenhouse trial,
but and this this judge may have done odd things,
but I feel like he's been significantly more
professional. And we're going to get to, you
know, a lot of the very strange things that
were said by the Rittenhouse judge,
Speaker 3: uncharged Piccolo's
Speaker 1: that being one of them. I actually
like how this judge has been running the case, but
everything about it. We can't have black pastors
coming through. I've been asked to apologize
to judges like I didn't ask you to. That's not
kind of neither here nor there. And if anybody,
I apologize if anyone was offended, it's like the
quintessential non-apology apology. But there it
is. So things not in the Rittenhouse case,
the judge is more the cartoon in this trial,
it's more the defense attorney. So send
me your thoughts on this. You can find
me on Twitter at De Packman and then after the
break, we'll talk about Judge Bruce Schroeder
in the Kyle Rittenhouse trial. Welcome back to the
show. I invite you to subscribe on my website for
extra content every day produced specifically for
our members. You can sign up at join the Packman
dot com. It takes just a minute or so and you get
instant daily access to the bonus show. It's an
additional show we do every day for our paid
members. You also get a commercial free audio
feed if you would prefer you get a commercial free
video feed if you prefer. We also have a member's
specific line that you can use to call in when we
do our viewer town halls. We did one a couple of
weeks ago. We've got another one that I'm going
to be announcing very soon and very strongly,
I might add. And our members also get priority
access to me during the viewer town hall. So all
of those member benefits and more are available
for not a lot of money, folks, really not a lot
of money. And if you would like an even littler
amount of money, you can use the coupon code
better 21 to get a huge discount on my website.
Join Packman dot com. Appreciate everybody
who signed up over the last couple of weeks.
We've had a nice little influx of new members.